this is known as an ant Mill an
unsettling phenomenon where army ants
March in a spiral Trapped In This creepy
ritualistic behavior until they die from
exhaustion why do army ants do this
spiral of death normally ants follow
Trails of pheromones left behind by
other ants but if a lead ant encounters
an obstacle it may have to turn around
or find another route sometimes causing
the trail to loop back in on itself the
following ants may get stuck in that
Loop and the more ants that follow the
loop the more the looping pheromone
Trail gets reinforced alternatively if
the following ants lose the pheromone
Trail altogether they end up following
each other in a rotating hopeless Circle
of Death the ants have a hard time
breaking out of this Loop and often end
up dying in Mass